good morning everybody I just met with  Donald toast the President of the  European Council where I agreed an  extension to the brexit process to the  end of October at the latest I continue  to believe we need to leave the EU with  the deal as soon as possible  and finally the EU have agreed that the  extension can be terminated when the  withdrawal agreement has been ratified  which is my key request of my fellow  leaders for example this means that if  we're able to pass a deal in the first  three weeks of May we will not have to  take part in European elections and will  officially leave the EU on Saturday the  first of June during the course of the  extension the European Council is clear  that the UK will continue to hold firm  ownership rights as well as its  obligations as I said in the room